a cruise missile launched by houti
rebels in Yemen has struck a commercial
vessel in the Red Sea the Norwegian flag
ship called the strina was hit 60
nautical miles north of the bab mandab
straight the missile caused a fire and
damage to the vessel no casualties were
reported its owners say it was carrying
palm oil to Italy and was heading
towards the sews Canal but a houti
spokesperson says the ship was targeted
because the group believed it was
transporting crude oil to Israel and
failed to heed warnings to change
course in support of the oppressed
Palestinian people currently reeling
under the destruction killing and Siege
in the Gaza Strip and to heed the calls
of our Free yemeni People the yemeni
naval forces carried out an outstanding
military operation against MV strenda
from Norway loaded with oil and headed
to the Israeli entity The Vessel was
targeted with the appropriate Naval
Strike missile
over the past two days the yemeni Armed
Forces prevented a number of vessels
from passing through those vessels heed
our warnings the Norwegian vessel was
attacked only after its crew turned a
deaf ear to all our warnings the Yemen
Armed Forces will not hesitate to attack
any vessel that may disobey our earlier
statements we reiterate that we will
continue to prevent all vessels
regardless of their nationalities headed
to the Israeli sea ports from navigating
in the Arab or Red Sea until the
necessary food and medical supplies are
delivered to our brothers in the Gaza
Strip